actually you teach as as well don't you
you do and now this
is so adorable you posted this uh film
and it's you teaching your daughter
rose i mean i say teach you dr rose
uh you'll see this is just it's
[Music]
beautiful
me a minute to hold my girl
give me a minute to hold my girl
i've got time i've got love
got confidence you rise above
give me a minute to hold my girl
give me a minute to hold my
[Music]
pick gun place to rest your head
and give me a minute
give me a minute to hold my girl
oh
i mean there are going to be
ovaries exploding all up down the land
i mean that was back when she liked me
now now she just doesn't want to see me
doesn't want to see me at all but oh
that is literally that is one of those
moments i will never forget
it wasn't planned we were you know me
and the boys were in the studio
and you know obviously rose was there
and warren's little girl was there and
jordan's son was and i was like oh this
is the first time that we've all been
together in the studio should we like
just do a dance and literally i was like
just give me five minutes and i just
sort of like made it up and then we
recorded it and i was just like this is
just the moment
it's amazing beautiful isn't it
something about because
like a month old she was she was it was
literally to celebrate her month
like kind of not birthday but yeah four
weeks of like being here and it was her
first time in the studio
yeah so a lovely moment
you